je vous parle aujourd'hui du monde
connecté monde connecté fossiles la
dernière monde connecté de cinquième
génération fossiles qui à mon poignet
était juste là qui juste avant était
dans cette boîte la bombe qui écoute qui
a plein davantage surtout une autonomie
je dirais un peu personnalisable ça
c'est intéressant ce qu'on peut faire
beaucoup de choses vous pouvez la
paramétrer justement au niveau de
l'autonomie la règle et comme vous le
souhaitez il ya un capacité de stockage
qui est accrue il ya un meilleur haut
parleurs en falco qui est vraiment
intéressant je propose c'est qu'on en
parle juste maintenant
[Musique]
bon je sais pas si vous savez on est
dans le tout nouveau studio si pour
l'instant je vous montre pas je reste un
petit peu je dirais discret là c'est
quoi un peu podcast peut éventuellement
me faire apparaître un bout de micro
juste là on en reparlera d'ici quelques
temps pour parler justement de cette non
de fossiles dans cette fosse il est là
plein de points hyper hyper hyper hyper
intéressant ce que je vous propose c'est
qu'on prend un peu de hauteur à se
mettre au dessus comme ça on regarde et
puis à vous de me dire ce que vous en
pensez bien évidemment on va en
commentaire bon la boîte est assez
simple ça marche dans notre plan donnera
quand ça commence bien
votre montre est posée là dessus ça
fonctionne ça c'est simple c'est assez
efficace à l'intérieur vous avez de quoi
avoir quelques petites informations sur
votre smart one common la recharger tout
ça donc ça c'est franchement cool
vous avez bien évidemment un grand livre
et avec plein de choses écrit dans plein
de langue s'ils voulaient apprendre les
langues sont aussi très pratique mais
surtout le truc qui est cool c'est votre
montre qui est franchement en elle même
très chaud gars avant de vous montrer
des tags allégeons que le chargeur elles
se rechargent extrêmement facilement
alors gelé hop un petit peu repliés
comme ça en fait
elle vient se poser directement là
dessus elles se chargent très facilement
de l'autre côté vous le mettez sur un
ordinateur ou sur un petit adaptateur
sauf fois sur un petit un petit bloc car
attention recharge rapide parce qu'il
faut pas venir endommager votre votre
montre la montre en elle-même moi
personnellement j'aime bien gallas a
parfaitement bien à mon premier c'est
pas des énormes poignet mais je peux la
mettre très facilement via l'attaché de
façon un peu classique avec son son
bracelet
si vous la regardez un peu tous les
côtés c'est vrai qu'elle fonctionne
parfaitement bien c'est vraiment un
produit qui est très très bien finie
alors j'ai un petit peu ce que vous
voyez on peut bien changer le bracelet
extrêmement facilement donc c'est vrai
que d'un point de vue purement
esthétique en tout cas c'est quelque
chose qui est très bien réussi j'aime
beaucoup le travail est ainsi parfois
aussi là dessus
cela vous avez un boîtier de 44 mm pour
venir complètement la personnaliser au
niveau du bracelet
tout est fait en acier inoxydable que ce
soit le cadran que ce soit les boutons
donc là dessus vous êtes vraiment
tranquille vous partez sur un produit de
bonne qualité point de vue
on n'est pas forcé monde c'est le
nouveau haut-parleur étanche qui vous
permettra effectivement de répondre à
vos appels téléphoniques de pouvoir
passer beaucoup de fils est d'abord
aussi google directement de l'intégrer
au quai google
quel temps fait-il aujourd'hui selon les
prédictions à paris aujourd'hui le ciel
sera partiellement couvert avec une
température maximale prévue aventure
minimale à 17 degrés c'est parfait alors
vous avez mon smartphone qui chantent la
même météo à côté notre cas c'est cool
haut parleurs qui est suffisamment
puissant ça chauffe ça vraiment bien et
ça vous permet de répondre à vos appels
sur android assez bien mais à partir de
l'automne d'avoir une application pour
ios vous avez un écran bien évidemment
complètement tactile vous pouvez venir
utiliser moi je vais beaucoup et je
trouve vraiment cool cet écran très
facile à manipuler
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
vraiment hyper hyper agréable
complètement personnalisable dans sa c
du rer ce message et vous le détailler
dans quelques instants il ya des gros
points forts de cette montre c'est la
partie autonomie vous venez ici vous
allez sur batterie là vous allez avoir
tous vos modes de batterie vous êtes
vraiment pouvoir tenir la personnaliser
alors plusieurs modes je vous explique
vous avez tout d'abord le mode quotidien
vous allez avoir la plupart des
fonctionnalités qui vont être activés
l'écran toujours allumée et activer le
haut parleur et activer le wifi
l'emplacement sur demande aux actifs a
brillé pas mal faut activer certaines
choses qui sont désactivés vous avez une
autonomie qui peut se tendent à relate
sud ça marche ça fonctionne
vous avez ensuite le mode étendu ça vous
permettra d'avoir une durée de vie
prolongée
vous allez voir plusieurs heures
d'autonomie avec des fonctionnalités
essentielles notamment tout ce qui va
être je dirais une notification
fréquence cardiaque il ya certaines
choses qui vont être désactivée
forcément falloir grenier un petit peu
votre bluetooth qui activaient
uniquement 2 6 heures du matin à 10
heures du soir
si vous voulez avant la nuit il va
falloir changer de mode il ya pas mal de
petites choses désactivé mais là je dire
que vous allez gagner vraiment en
autonomie voyez notification active et
vibrations activée bon c'est vraiment
les fonctions essentielles
personnellement moi ce que je préfère
c'est la partie personnalisée parce que
là si vous qui allez choisir réellement
vous activer ou désactiver faites ce que
vous voulez donc assez correspond
réellement à vos usages et ça pour moi
c'est ce qu'a lieu et c'est vraiment
génial regarder incliner pour allumer
l'écran je n'ai pas mis nfc les familles
auraient google je l'aimé parce que je
l'utilisé le bluetooth actifs a grillé
pas mal de petites choses et c'est vous
qui choisissez c'est vous qui venez
vraiment régler votre montre pour avoir
l'autonomie que vous voulez selon vos
visages
donc ça pour moi c'est vraiment génial
et ensuite vous allez avoir le mode
affiché seulement leur là ça va venir
uniquement vous afficher l'heure mais
l'intérêt de ce mode là
c'est lorsque vous arrivez enfin de
batteries en fin de course que vous
n'avez plus de batterie et bien
justement vous l'activez vous aurez au
moins leurs dons qu'elle jouera un rôle
de montres uniquement pas deux mondes
connectés mais c'est pas grave ça me
servira quand même croyez-moi ça peut
être vraiment cool grâce à ses
différents modes on part donc sur une
autonomie de aller un jour et demi à
plusieurs jours donc ça va dépendre une
fois de plus de vos besoins mais
croyez-moi ça c'est vraiment cool c'est
vraiment superbe que fos il nous est
permis de dire complètement personnalisé
l'autonomie en fonction des
fonctionnalités convenir activer ou
désactiver en plus ce qui est cool si
vous avez de la recharge rapide en une
heure pour les recharger à 80 % ça c'est
aussi super cool du côté performances
vous avez un qualcomm snapdragon were
3101 giga de ram et 8 gigas de stockage
on pouvait mettre directement votre
musique
à l'intérieur un jeune arabe ma femme
d'à côté d'être connecté lorsque vous
allez courir si vous voulez courir en
tout cas l'utiliser lui vous prenez vous
mettez des petits écouteurs bluetooth ou
synchroniser directement avec votre
monde votre musique à l'intérieur et
vous partez directement sur les chemins
faire votre compte donc ça c'est plutôt
cool
l' os et au web os de google vous avez
la dernière version qui est vraiment
couleur je sais pas si vous êtes
coutumier de héros est soit
partiellement j'aime beaucoup regarder
tous fait une petite démo là vous avez
soit côté toutes vos parties je dirais
un petit peu sport usage ce que vous
avez fait aujourd'hui combien de temps
vous allez marcher
combien de port vous avez gagné bien sûr
ça dépend complètement de vous à moi je
tourne c'est le matin alors que je suis
encore un mode un petit peu un petit peu
cool vote météo vous allez retrouver ce
que vous devez venir acheter chercher
compagnie voilà après vous pouvez venir
ajouter des cartes les modifier donc là
haut up voyez vous revenez dans votre
accueil vous balayer la côté vous avez
votre assistant personnel avec vous
rendez vous qui vont arriver
vos événements vous retrouve un peu
c'est pareil la météo google assistance
ça c'est vraiment cool vous balayer sur
le bas vous avez toutes vos
notifications tous vos emails et nageant
des impacts et croyez moi et vous verrez
ensuite balayé l'autre côté vous
retrouvez je dirais vos paramètres de
base mode avion votre mode batterie qui
est juste allons vous parler à quelques
instants le fait de mettre les bonnes ne
pas déranger active et google paye est
ici tous vos paramètres pour ni a
complètement personnaliser votre monde
que ce soit au niveau de l'écran au
niveau du son peut venir régler la
luminosité suisse mettant au point qu as
tu peux mettre enceinte mais si on
s'arrête plus énergivore donc attention
sun light boost pour revenir vous passez
sur la gauche taille de la police oui
vous avez plein de choses à me régler
pareil au niveau du fond des
applications les gestes connectivité
donc surtout qui serait du bien qui est
très personnalisable et c'est un des
groupes point fort de cette note ensuite
vous avez trois boutons sur le côté ça
ne vous aura pas échappé
là
ainsi pour créer des catégories moi
j'utilise pas pour le moment le bouton
du bar à vous servir pour la partie
exercice fitness marche à pied course à
pied vélo à tout ce que vous voulez donc
ça c'est plutôt intéressant et là sur le
bouton du mieux vaut avoir toutes vos
applications saas et couleurs la vraie
aux différentes applis notamment google
traduction hop français anglais
bonjour comment vas tu es là il
reconnaît et l'ohio donc comme ça vous
veniez vraiment lorsque vous êtes à
l'étranger pouvoir communiquer
facilement occasion en tout cas leur
faire lire on ça peut être cool pour vos
paramètres votre trad vous l'avez vu
spotify votre musique les alarmes le cas
de grains pour savoir où est ce que vous
allez être là je pense que je suis un
peu speed vu tout de suite en plein
effort et 103 on est au tac hausse le
chronomètre les commandes multimédias
les contacts bien évidemment tout ce qui
va être exercice la respiration l'appli
fossiles google paye ta lampe de poche
localiser le téléphone la météo better
for ya pas mal de petits trucs et vous
avez bien évidemment le plat histoire
pour mir télécharger plein
d'applications supplémentaires si vous
en avez besoin de ça c'est franchement
aussi complètement génial on peut venir
lui mettre tout ce que vous voulez
intérieur recommandé pour vous par
exemple
messenger télégramme fait ce que vous
ferez donc face tout ça vraiment
vraiment vraiment cool téléphone
traduction travail et donc il ya pas mal
de petits possibilité de prévenir aussi
personnaliser votre écran vous laissait
depuis dessus vous choisissez votre
écran et après il y en a plein d'autres
infos venir ans voire plus si si vous
choisissez ce que vous voulez vous
faites comme vous voulez donc ça c'est
cool ya pas mal pas mal de possibilités
vous avez du bluetooth 4 points de
l'intérieur gps directement pouvoir
venir vous traquez lorsque vous allez
faire votre course à pied bien
évidemment un capteur de fréquence
cardiaque pour savoir où est-ce que vous
en êtes comment vous allez et comment
vous allez courir pour avoir un suivi
donc ça c'est aussi cool du nfc pour le
paiement dématérialisé pour google paie
un altimètre un accéléromètre un
gyroscope un capteur de lumière ambiante
est bien évidemment un micro pour
pouvoir passer vos coups de filets par
la google c'est une monde qui étanche
jusqu'à 3 atm vous pouvez aller sous
l'eau vous valez nager avec vous êtes
tranquille et qui est dispo au tarif de
299 euros d'ailleurs si l intérêt ce qui
nous a mis un lien en bas dans la
description mais par contre la 3d on va
bouger un petit peu par là comment vous
la trouvez cette plante à ce qu'on va
trouver intéressante est ce qu'elles
pourraient vous tentez moi
personnellement je trouve cool j'aime
bien avoir à mon bras c'est la trouve
très sport justement avec ce bracelet
silicone intéressés vous pouvez venir le
changer si vous n'êtes pas de race et
silicone soul et la personnaliser vous
pouvez le faire la customiser très
facilement sa sékouba c'est quand même
pas mal de possibilités il à rendre un
petit peu plus
chic avec différents types de bracelets
moi je trouve vraiment bien cool bon
format rapide facile de prise en main et
surtout personnalisable le fait de
pouvoir choisir et bien sûr mode de
batteries en fonction de vos usages
réels ça c'est vachement bien passé
permet de la prolonger dans le temps et
c'est souvent un des points noirs d'une
montre notamment si vous prenez par
exemple une apple watch elle va durer
une journée pas plus bas ça c'est un
petit peu le point de regret là par
contre vous faites ce que vous voulez
vous pouvez l'emmener très loin et ça
c'est vraiment cool a vous de me dire ce
que vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
quant à lyon se retrouve très bientôt
pour continuer à parler peut-être croyez
moi il ya plein de choses qui arrivent
plein de belles surprises donc ça ça va
être cool à bientôt j'embrasse ciao
non